Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
I am Farron Cousins sitting in for David Pakman
this week. We do have to talk about Joe Manchin.
I know we've talked about him every day this week,
but obviously as the week has progressed, more
and more stuff has happened. And one of those
things happens to be actress Bette Midler. Now,
what happened with Bette Midler, you're asking,
well, if you've been on social media, I'm sure
you've seen it. Bette Midler, and I guess you
would call it a fit of anger about Joe Manchin.
Excuse me, tanking, build back better, send out a
tweet that she later apologized for. So here's the
original tweet. What Joe Manchin, who represents
a population smaller than Brooklyn has done to
the rest of America who wants to move forward,
not backward like his state is horrible. He sold
us out. He wants us all to be just like his state,
West Virginia poor, illiterate and strung out. And
dang it, if you hadn't added that last sentence.
Probably would have been OK, but obviously
it's not fair to attack an entire state in this
country. All the citizens of it for the actions of
the man they continue to send to the Senate. You
know what? I kind of understand it, I truly do.
And of course, as I mentioned, Midler then came
out apologized for it. Here's her apology tweet. I
apologize to the good people of West Virginia for
my outburst. I'm just seeing Red Joe Manchin,
his whole family or a criminal enterprise.
Is he really the best West Virginia has to
offer its own citizens? Surely there's someone,
someone there who has the state's interests at
heart, not his own good enough apology, right?
I'm OK with that. In fact, to be honest, I'm not
even mad at Bette Midler for the original tweet,
and that may give me some hate. I understand
it's not something I would have said.
In my younger years, actually, I probably
would have said something like that, but no,
was it? Was it fair? Probably not. And, of course,
some of the things she said actually weren't even
that accurate illiterate. No. West Virginia is
actually 16th lowest literacy rate in the country.
The top four states are California,
New York, Florida and Texas.
Because the larger the population, the larger the
likelihood that you have more illiterate citizens,
so West Virginia is not even in the top 10 and
most illiterate states. So that was that was
a low blow. That was also factually inaccurate.
The other points, though poverty, they've got the
sixth highest poverty rate in the country, 31st
in unemployment. So not too bad, right? They got
a 6.3 unemployment rate based on the numbers I saw
so well above the national average. But of course,
certainly not at the top, not at the bottom,
just kind of right there in the middle. One area,
however. Is what should scare the hell out of West
Virginians, and this is something. Especially with
the environmental provisions from build back
better. That needs to be hit on repeatedly.
The cancer rate in West Virginia
is the 48th highest in the nation,
the highest, of course, being Kentucky.
But that cancer rate. Is due partially to the
industrial pollution it's due to the coal mining
operations in West Virginia. But the industrial
pollution in West Virginia is well-documented,
I happen to work with Mike Papantonio, who
has handled multiple environmental lawsuits
in West Virginia, where people left and right have
been poisoned by megacorporations for decades and
the poisons, the toxins they've dumped into these
rivers and streams and into the environment itself
is still causing cancer to this day. That hasn't
gone away. And as long as people like Joe Manchin
fight back against environmental protections,
you're going to continue to see these very high
cancer rates. So those are the kinds of things
really that Bette Midler should have hit upon.
Of course, I understand she didn't have time.
She she's not a political researcher. She's not
involved in political media in any way. So she
she spoke from the heart. And sometimes when
you do that, you say things that you really
ought not say. And of course, you loop in
and blame people and basically make fun of them
for things that aren't true and it's not fair.
The people of West Virginia absolutely
deserve better than Joe Manchin.
But at the end of the day, they keep
sending them back to the Senate.
You know, just like the people of Kentucky deserve
better than Rand Paul and Mitch McConnell yet.
Mitch McConnell's been sent back to
the Senate since I was two years old.
Rand Paul, not quite as long, but if he stays in
politics, I promise you, we will be. It's just
the nature of the Beast, right? People want to
stick with what's comfortable with what they know
because they aren't afraid that their lives are
going to get better at this point. I think that's
never a possibility or I think they think it's not
a possibility. They're just worried their lives
could get worse with somebody different.
So that's what we have to fix.
That's what we have to address with these people,
these residents in these areas. They keep electing
horrible people like Joe Manchin. We need to
explain to them that there are better options
that sometimes it's OK to take that risk and
vote for somebody you don't know whose name
isn't familiar. Joe Manchin, obviously well-known
throughout West Virginia. More well-known across
America today than I'm sure Manchin ever wanted
to be. So that's up to us to educate these people,
to help them understand that they deserve better
and they can have better. Look at it this way.
Joe Manchin blocking build back better is,
of course, harmful to the very citizens
that he represents in West Virginia. But it's
harmful to the entire United States as well.
Goldman Sachs came out they revised their economic
outlook for the year 2022, had to revise it down
based on Joe Manchin statement. They've also
told us that killing this bill is going to
starve the United States economy next year of 60
billion dollars, $60 billion. First quarter GDP
growth for next year was revised down from three
percent to two percent, a full percentage point
in terms of GDP. That's a relatively big deal
for one man's vote on one piece of legislation.
That's how powerful he is.
He shouldn't be. There's absolutely no
reason Joe Manchin should have this power.
And that, of course, is what sets people like
Bette Midler off its sets, all of us off. So
while I don't agree necessarily. With how she said
what she said. I do understand it to a degree. And
of course, she did apologize. So I have no
problem with this. She did a good job there.
But we shouldn't focus on, oh, she screwed
up, no, we should focus on the anger that she
has and understand that that is not limited to
Bette Midler. We're all angry. Every one of us.
But we need to turn that anger into action.
We need to turn the anger into education.
We need to help people understand because look,
I'm in Florida. I don't get to vote for Joe
Manchin. I will never vote for Joe Manchin, ever
in my life, even if I did live in West Virginia.
But it's still up to us to let people know
you deserve better and you can have better.
You just have to take that gamble on a name that's
not familiar to you. And trust me, folks, that is
so hard to convince people to do. But the country
may not have much of a choice. So we have to